un machin famille on va débuter cette
cette journée de travail
cette nouvelle journée de travail des
républicains nous avions traité vous le
savez des sujets concernant le code du
travail
nous avons traité des sujets concernant
les l'émigration l'immigration et nous
traitons maintenant aujourd'hui il
sujets concernant la sécurité
donc le projet des républicains avance à
bon train et va continuer d'ailleurs à
un rythme encore plus important puisque
nous avons rendez vous dans une dizaine
de jours sur la l'agriculture et la
ruralité et puis avant les élections
régionales nous traiterons du sujet de
l'évolution de la fonction publique pour
chacun de ces thèmes des groupes de
travail composés d'élus nombreux élus
experts se réunissent et puis en même
temps d'autres groupes de travail
continue à travailler sur tous les
autres sujets jusqu'à ce que une
convention vienne n'ont pas clôturé
clôturer la réflexion ce serait stupide
de le dire mais en même temps posé des
points précis de programmes sur le sujet
donc la sécurité est un sujet évidemment
au coeur des préoccupations des français
au fond deux sujets qui sont au coeur
des préoccupations de nos concitoyens de
nos préoccupations
d'un côté ce chômage de masse et on aura
à partir du mois de janvier évidemment
un cycle économique et social mais aussi
bien sur les questions de sécurité alors
sécurité au sens large du terme souvent
sécurité au sens défense nationale
sécurité au sens justice et sécurités
évidemment au sens de sécurité
intérieure et c'est le thème de cette
journée même si sur certains éléments
ces trois points sont presque
indissociables dans les peurs des
français
nous avons choisi de nous concentrer sur
les questions de sécurité intérieure
pour ce faire il y aura trois tables
rondes après le l'ouverture par brice
hortefeux qui fera un bilan de l'échec
de la politique de sécurité du
gouvernement
et puis brigitte kuster animera une
table ronde sur les missions de nos
forces de l'ordre quelles sont ses
missions
c'est d'ailleurs une question qu'on doit
se poser sur l'ensemble des missions de
l'état et plus largement des
collectivités locales quelles sont les
missions de la sphère publique
tout ça est entre alliés bien sûr aussi
à la dépense publique et puis une autre
table ronde présidée par bruno beschizza
sur l'organisation des forces et des
moyens pour cette sécurité une fois
qu'on a ciblé et indiqué qu'elles
étaient les missions évidemment il faut
par ailleurs bien regarder avec quels
moyens
ces missions peuvent être remplies et
puis sujet majeur pour terminer cette
demi journée très très dense avec
georges fenech
la question de la justice donc 2 de
l'application des peines de l'exécution
des peines de la politique pénale sans
lesquels évidemment il peut pas y avoir
de sécurité c'est une une procédure
longue c'est un fil conducteur entre la
police et la justice et on évoquera ce
point on reviendra sur les questions jus
de type de justice plus particulièrement
à partir de l'année prochaine
et bien évidemment vers midi comme nous
en avons l'habitude
nicolas sarkozy viendra de conclure
cette demi journée consacrée aux
questions de sécurité je passe ce
immédiatement la parole à brice
hortefeux